>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Hi, I'm Mark Horowitz from
the Music Division of the Library
of Congress and I'm here with the
master musician Jason Robert Brown
and we're here mostly
to discuss music.
I don't know if you, we called
this sort of oral history
but it's going to be fairly focused.
>> Is there something else I
would be qualified to discuss?
>> I wanted to start, there is an
aphorism attributed to Ned Rorem
and it goes something like
amateurs talk about meanings
and professionals talk about means.
What I want to know first is
the physical how you work.
Do you work at a piano, do you
have a computer next to you,
do you record as you're
playing, do you make notes?
>> I feel like I'm
sort of in the middle
of changing how all of that works.
It used to be that I would sit at
the piano and sort of bang things
out and you know, I would know,
before I sat down at the
piano I would have a title,
usually I'd have a precede of what
the song was going to be in my head
which I'd encapsulated in a couple
of words and so I would sing
that title and I'd have
an instinctive sense
of what is the tonality, is
it a major key, minor key,
and what is the style of
it, is it sort of jazzy,
is it sort of rocky, is
it sort of classical?
And you know, the basic parameters
around that so before I sit
down at the piano I've already
made a couple of decisions
but then the piano is going to start
influencing a bunch of the decisions
that I make from there on out.
And so, I'll start singing along and
gradually sort of carve out a shape
of a melody or at the very
least a harmonic progression
and some rhythmic ideas in terms
of where the melody is
going to live within that.
So, I'll do all of
that and sort of come
up with a basic structure
for how the song works.
I usually will stop at the
bridge and just leave the bridge
for a minute but just get those
first chunks done you know,
what's the verse structure,
what's the chorus structure
and am I using a conventional
structure or am I going
to ski the powder and sort
of see where it leads me.
And you know, I'll sort of start
making those decisions as I carve it
out and then gradually
fitting words to it and some
of the words will have come
up as I've started just singing
things randomly at the piano.
Some words will sort of find
their way into my subconsciousness
because I mean, I know again
what the character is thinking
so there's certain phrases that
I'll start just sort of improvising
and those might suddenly I'll go,
oh and that actually fits nicely
over this and then that rhymes
nicely with that and then oh,
I see where I want to go.
So all of that stuff is going on and
it's all sort of very free formed
but it's directed you
know, it's not random.
I always know sort of what
the end result should be,
it just takes me a lot of
synthesizing to get there.
And then, once I've got
a basic verse structure
and a basic chorus structure, I will
usually go away and just chip away
at lyrics for a while and just
sort of get all that to line up
and there are oftentimes where I
never get back to the piano again
until the first time I'm
showing the song to somebody,
which may even include a
bridge that I've written
and I just know what
it is in my head
but I've never actually put my
fingers on the keys to do it,
but you know they'll be someone
coming over to hear the song
and I'll be like oh, and I'll
just pull it out of the printer
and I'll say all right here it was.
And I try to write lyrics by hand
because I sort of think better
through my pen then I do
when I'm typing but again,
it depends on the deadline.
I can sort of do it however but
I don't notate score usually
until the very end of
the process because much
of what I'm doing is
chordally based as so as long
as I know what the general harmonic
progression is I'm not so caught
up in the specifics
of the accompaniment
or I know what they are so
specifically that I don't have
to write them down for a while,
but I actually prefer the
organic letting it come
out of my hands first, let my
hands get used to what the feel
of the song is and then I
will start really shaping it
into the notated accompaniment.
But when I say that I'm in
the middle of changing that,
when I did Bridges of Madison County
I wrote most of that on guitar,
which is not an instrument
that I really play but I wanted
to have tonalities that were not
what I usually hit with my fingers
and so because I was writing on
an instrument that I didn't know,
I couldn't just call up a bunch
of things that I knew how to do.
That was much more of an exploratory
process where I would just pick
up the guitar and sit with it and
just sort of make noises on it
and as I would come up with
shapes, accompaniment figures,
structural ideas, I would say does
this feel like this character,
does that feel like what I
want this moment to feel like?
And as I got a little more fluent on
the instrument, and I never got good
at it but as I got more fluent
on it, I eventually was able
to anticipate some things and was
able to make certain decisions ahead
of time but I'd say the first three
or four things I wrote for Bridges
of Madison County on the
guitar were very sort of like,
I don't know what's going to happen
and I liked that sort of looseness
and craziness, but within
that looseness then the rest
of the process was very similar.
Once I would sort of see a
light at the end of the tunnel,
then I knew how to sort
of push towards it.
But lately, I've also been doing a
lot more of recording stuff as I'm
in the middle of writing it and then
just letting it marinate for a while
or sometimes I'll layer
recordings on top of each other
and I'll use the garage bands
on my Mac and sort of let
that be a template for things.
There was one project that I
had to write very, very quickly
and it all had to be
very idiomatic music,
it all needed to be really
rock music and I found
that I just used the drum loops from
garage band which are very generic
and I just used those, and I didn't
use any of the harmonic loops
that they have on there
because that felt like cheating
but I used the drum loops and just
played along with them and I felt
like oh, now I feel like I'm in that
band and that's doing that thing
for me so I did that, but
I don't think I would do
that for a more legit project.
This was for a commercial
thing that I was doing.
>> You've talked a lot about the
importance of structure in songs
so when you have this initial
idea, do you have a sense
that this is going to be, the A
section will be about this topic,
then it will go here
and the bridge will go
that direction or it's not that-
>> I sort of, I feel like
there are a lot of songs
where I may have outlined
that in advance.
There are certainly, I
think the vast majority
of my songs you can diagram
them that way after the fact.
>> But not going into it?
>> Well, I think going
in it's very clear
to me what I'm doing
with the first verse.
I always know where the song is
starting and then I will need
to do something else
for the second verse
because I have a real
philosophy about the way
that theater songs have to function
and what justifies repetition
because to me, it feels
like if the music is going
to repeat itself them dramatically
you can't be repeating yourself.
The lyrics have to be taking you
someplace else and when I teach,
I often have a think I talk about
how if you're going to be trying
to convince somebody of
something you might say it to them
and if they didn't get it
you might say it again,
but you're not just going to say
it a third time without trying
to find some other way around
it, some way to elaborate into it
and so I always think of that
as the B section is bridge
and then the final A.
>> But dramatically, you
know where you're starting.
Do you know where you want
that character to end?
>> If you're lucky you do.
If I'm honest with
who the character is,
then I should know before I start
the song what I hope for it to end
with but I say that and I
have been surprised often
by where the characters take me
over the course of writing the song
and sometimes it's something
as simple as a rhyme is going
to lead me over here and
because the rhyme led me there,
suddenly the character
feels something
and learns something that's
not untrue to the character
but it may not have been what
I intended the song to say.
But having said it all of
a sudden, it lifts the song
and likewise I can have that
and then it sends the whole song
off the cliff and then I have
to go and rescue it back.
But I think in terms of the
sort of [inaudible] structure
over everything, there is always a
general sense that you're going to,
at some point over here if this is
the whole piece then at some point
over here there's going to be the
kind of ultimatum of the song,
there's going to be
some real turning point
about what the piece is and then the
resolution which is either positive
or negative or even stasis,
however things resolve from here.
But all of the thing
that gets you up to
that point is really asking the
questions and finding other ways
to ask the questions and I feel
like that's what the song always is.
The song is a series of
demands and questions trying
to lead up to a decision.
I think there are some songs
of mine that are very clear how
that all works, I was thinking
You Don't Know This Man is a song
that you know exactly
sort of what it's doing
because dramatically it's meant
to be sort of the first A,
she won't look at him
when she's talking
and then the second A
she looks directly at him
and then the bridge you know,
she really pins it right on him
and the finals statement, the final
A she shuts him down and I feel
like you really see
sort of what that is
because she's actually just talking
to herself over the course of that.
But then you know, something like
The Schmuel Song, which is seven
and a half minutes long, there is
still the exact same [inaudible]
structure to it but what it takes
in order to get there you know,
I remember while writing
it I don't know
when I'm going to get out of this.
You know, it was just sort of
taking me all of these places
and I was enjoying the ride and I
thought the song was benefitting
from the ride but I really thought
this song might be 20 minutes long,
it might be two minutes long,
I don't know because the path
over to here was so windy
that I just couldn't tell how long
it was going to take me to get there
and then when it did finally wrap up
it was like oh I see it, I see it,
I see it, I get it and then I
could sort of put a bow on it.
But you know, so I think those are
the kind of two extremes you know,
structurally of what my
songs are but you know,
I do always have a general sense
of what the song is supposed
to accomplish and then
there are tweaks
and specifics that I think get all-
>> And there's surprises
to you as it goes along.
>> Yeah, I mean to me it's
the most fun when there are.
You know, if it's exactly
what you thought it was going
to be then really you're just
being a secretary to your brain,
which is not as much fun.
You know, what there really
is, is there's this thing
where your brain does,
it makes some leap
that you didn't know it was going to
make and that's why you're a writer.
I mean, that's why I'm a writer.
It's just those moments
where you're like oh, oh,
I didn't know that was coming and
I didn't know that was going to be
that and that's perfect, that's
exactly what that's supposed to be
and I have such a sense of pride
in those moments and such a sense
of accomplishment in those moments.
That's sort of what
I'm working towards.
It's why I write slowly also
is I don't want to just sort
of all right, I know what
this song is and I write it.
I think I always could, I
think I could do that now
if you said write it, I could
just go ahead and write it
but the real joy is in
making all of it sort
of click together exactly right in
some way that I can't see right now.
>> Somewhere you wrote I think
in the intro to something,
to the libretto for
The Last Five Years,
that you remember writing
the opening number
on this particular day.
Is there a typical time that it
takes to write a song, a range?
>> I think the reason I can
tell you I wrote that song
on any particular day or anything
like that is there are those moments
where a song sort of
clicks, they're very powerful
and so a song can take three weeks
to write but there is a moment
in which the song sort
of coalesces into a thing
and that can be you know, when
you're two weeks in to trying
to figure it out or
it can be just sort
of on the first minute
that you have it.
I mean, there are certainly,
even recently there are
songs I've written very,
very quickly that just
sort of poured out of me
that were very satisfying.
Actually, the last two songs
that I wrote there's a song
that I'm writing for the
connector which is very,
very complicated long sort of
rap, punk, crazy thing that I did
and it took me the better part
of three months to write it
because it was just so dense and
the information had to be parsed
in exactly the right way so
the audience could hear it.
And it just took me a long time to
figure out how to do all of that
and then there was the song I
wrote the day after the election
which was Hope, which I wrote in I
think 18 or 19 minutes and you know,
both immensely satisfying
songs to me but you know,
the process by which they all
come is sort of a little crazy.
But I remember the day I finished up
the song for The Connector as well.
>> What is The Connector?
>> The Connector is one of the
new pieces that I'm working on.
>> It's a show?
>> It's a show, yes.
>> When you're writing a show song
versus a stand along song like Hope,
is it an entirely different thing,
you're writing for your voice,
not for a character in a situation?
>> It's not an entirely different
thing but it's a different thing.
Knowing that I'm going to
sing it generally means also
that my band is going to play
it so there are different things
that I do musically when
I'm writing for myself
but without sounding pretentious
about it, there is myself
as a character, there
is myself as the person
on stage singing the
song which is a thing.
You know, it's different than me
sitting at the dining room table.
I wouldn't be singing so
there is a certain distance.
It is an intangible and unmeasurable
distance between me and that guy
but there is still a
character involved in that
and when I'm writing a
character for a show,
then I'm definitely
inside a different person.
There are even times when
I'm writing songs for shows
that I know I'm going to want to
do in my act, that I know I'm going
to want to do with my band and
I do approach those differently.
I find that the songs I write for
the guys I tend to really think
about am I going to want to sing
this whereas the songs I write
for the girls I tend not to think
that because I'm not likely to
and then sometimes I'll end up with
one where like, oh I have to do this
and I'll make accommodations
for that.
But it is in my head and I
don't think it's a bad thing.
I think there's, because musical
theater is essentially meant to be
on a stage, it is meant
to be performed,
being able to anticipate
the performative aspects
of the material I think is part
of what makes my stuff what it is.
I mean, I think part of why my
songs breathe in the particular way
that they do is that I
know that I will need to,
physically myself I will need
to defend them behind a piano.
If I can't do it, then I can't
ask somebody else to do it.
>> Back to the original
sort of question,
when you sort of completed a
song, what do you physically do?
Do you write out a lead sheet?
Do you write a complete-
>> Oh no, no, no, at this point
when I'm done writing
a song I'll record it
and I'll do a pretty elaborate, I
mean obviously I have good fingers
so I can do a pretty elaborate piano
demo and if it needs musical means
that the piano does not
accurately represent,
if your imagination
would require a leap
that I can't expect your
imagination to take in order
to understand what the song is,
then I'll also put other things on.
I'll put percussion instruments on,
or I'll put my guitar playing on,
none of which is very good but
it's just to give you an idea
that this is not supposed
to sound like me sitting
at the piano so I'll make the demo.
I have one assistant who
transcribes just the vocal line
because that is really
just secretary work
and so they'll just transcribe the
vocal line for me and then sort
of any obvious piano figures,
anything that you can hear
in the accompaniment that I
clearly do over and over again,
that's something that
must be in there
and then leave the rest
of the piano part blank.
And so, they'll deliver to me a
finale file which has the vocal line
in it and sort of whatever of the
piano part was worth grabbing,
anything that will
save me a little time.
And when the singers first get the
material in a reading in a workshop,
usually that's all they get.
My Music Director Tom
Murray, will often sketch
in more complete accompaniments
but I deliberately keep those
out of my personal files because I
don't want to get sort of seduced
by how easy it is to just use those.
So Tom will sort of feather
in some fake accompaniment
so that he can play it at rehearsals
or so other rehearsal pianists
can do it and then eventually,
usually when it's time to
orchestrate I will first write
out a more fully realized
piano part even
if that isn't what the piano part
is going to be in the orchestration.
I just sort of like to reduce it
something that I can then work
from on a very concrete,
because orchestration
for me is still a very
concrete thing.
I know there's a lot of people that
just play things and the keyboards,
they work in a more abstract
way then that but for me I need
to see two stabs worth
of dots and I'm like,
okay now I know what I want to
do around it and I know enough
to eviscerate all of the dots
but for me that's a useful guide.
And again, if I have to work
really fast I don't need that,
I know what I have to do but in
the ideal world I'll realize an
accompaniment fairly fully
and that's the accompaniment
that will get in the
vocal selections,
that will get in the published
scores, that will sort of be all
that and then I'll
orchestrate it from there
if I'm doing the orchestration.
If someone else is
doing the orchestration,
if I send it to Sebesky or if I send
it to Charlie Rosen, or if I send it
to Sam Davis or anybody else
you know, then they'll usually,
Sebesky writes by hand and illegibly
so I'll get Sebesky's charts back
and I'll usually have to have the
copyist do that into a finale file
so that I can actually just read
what it is because it's just
like your doctor's prescription,
it's completely illegible
except to the copyist.
And so once I get that,
then I will do a lot
of corrections to anybody's charts.
I fix a lot of orchestrations,
I fiddle and so I'll correct,
if I get it from Charlie or from
Sam they'll send me finale files
and I'll usually do
the corrections right
into finale which I know how to use.
I'm not fast at it and I
don't like it very much.
There's something I like about
the tactility of pencils.
And so then that sort of goes off
into the world and I have a copyist
in Chicago who does the
vast majority of my work
and so then he'll get
all of it extracted
and then there's usually generations
upon generations upon generations
of fixes and cleanups and things
like that until you get to a place
where it can finally get published.
But for early shows like Songs For a
New World, those materials are still
in fairly lousy shape and that is
largely because it just takes me
so long to say what I
want the piano part to be.
And so everything that has to happen
thereafter goes really fast like,
I'm writing a piano part and here
are the orchestrations and go
and then everything is just fixes,
and fixes, and fixes, and fixes
and it costs money to fix all those
things, which I don't usually have
and nobody is generally
offering me so things can get
in pretty loosy goosy
shape for a while.
I think Parade we finally
have perfectly corrected
and fixed scores for full orchestra.
The show premiered in 1998, I
think I got those done in 2015.
>> Tunick uses a phrase
the eye that hears,
and as I understood him he sort
of visualizes the actual music
in his head as he's working, he
sort of sees the dots in his brain.
The fact that you're so, that you're
not writing things down initially
and you're a musician, what
are you holding in your brain?
Are you actually seeing the
music when you're playing things?
Is it-
>> No, I mean, I have layer.
I have layers that I sort of
am aware of layers of music
as I'm listening to
it, I hear in layers,
I sort of hear they compress
and then they expand.
I mean, that would be a pretty cool
visual idea to try and explain it
so I wasn't literate first, I
was an illiterate musician first.
I didn't come from the
dots out, I had a very,
very rudimentary you know, I
started when I was eight years old
and so I had a very rudimentary,
this is what a middle C is
and so I could do it
but I was just too lazy
and I preferred playing things.
You know there wasn't back
then any kind of school
of idiomatic piano playing other
than this is how you learn how
to play Liszt and this is how
you learn how to play Chopin,
which wasn't very interesting to
me and so I bailed out of that
and just became sort of a player
who played whatever I wanted to play
and it took me a long time
to get back to the dots.
And so, in the meantime I developed
a fairly extensive way of conceiving
of music and musical structures
that is not notation based.
I go in the other direction.
I think somebody like Tunick
started looking at paper and for me
by the time I looked at the paper,
by the time I knew really what
that meant, I was making
music for a long time already
so I can again synthesize
both of those things
because I've had enough experience
with looking at the paper
that I know how to make it make
sense but I think if you asked me
to visualize what one of
my songs is, a lot of it is
about the placement of
my fingers on the keys.
I know sort of what the cord
looks like under my hand
and because I also play without
really looking at my hands,
it's more that I just
know what it feels like.
I know what a song is supposed
to feel like under my fingers
and I don't even know that
that's a visual thing.
There's a muscular relationship to
my understanding of harmony and how
that drives through the song
so I think that's really,
I don't know that that makes
any sense when I say it
but no one has really asked me to
talk about it before but I think
if you asked me when I'm trying to
perform a song that I've written
for example, there are a number
of different sort of cues that are
in my head so I'm not following
a core in the sense of one
of those scores over there.
I'm not following a score but
there is a score in my head
and it's a bunch of sign posts and
some of those sign posts do consist
of literal written notation and
some of them consist of typed lyrics
on a page, or hand written lyrics
on a page, some of them consist
of oh your hands are supposed
to go to this place and some
of them are just memories about
where I was when I wrote the song.
There's something about that
that I go oh there's the thing
and it leads me to that's what
I'm supposed to do at that moment
because oh, I wrote this when
I was in London or I wrote this
when I was sitting and the kitchen
was over here and so I know that
and that's what gets me to there.
So, there's a whole
crazy thing of memory.
I remember I read a great story in
The New Yorker a couple of years ago
and it talked about storytellers
in India who they have a story
that lasts for an entire year
and it's an oral tradition
so that they are taught as
children, and if they are going
to become the storyteller
they are taught
as children how the
story goes and it lasts,
every night there is a chunk that
could be 20 minutes, an hour long,
whatever it is but every single
night of the year all 365
or however many, there is a part
of the story that they have to do
and they have these
memorized in their heads.
But they found that once these
people learned to read and write,
they actually become infinitely
less capable of holding all of that
in their memory, that you've
developed this incredible memory
because there's no way
to put it down on paper
but once you can put it on
paper, once you can do that,
once you can store
it somewhere else,
your brain says oh thank goodness
we don't have to do that anymore,
and it sheds some of it and
so I think part of my ability
to remember my scores
is because it comes
from not having notated
them in the first place.
It comes from having a series of
sort of things in my head and I find
that the songs that I do notate
first are the more kind of,
for lack of a better word, the
more serious classically kind
of things that I do.
When I have to notate them first, I
find that I have very little ability
to memorize them, it's very hard
for me to reproduce them accurately.
There's a chunk of Still Hurting
that is a fairly strict invention
in three parts and it's not just
that I can't really play it all
that well but after what's now been
15 years, I just know harmonically
where it's supposed to be but the
specific notes that are supposed
to happen in there, I'm always
like uh, and I've looked
at it a thousand times so that
I can do it in performances
and it just does not penetrate.
>> Every time you perform something,
this song will always
be in this key?
>> I can change the keys because I
know what the harmonic relationships
are but-
>> So the muscle memory can still-
>> Yeah, I mean I may not play it
as accurately in the key but I mean,
I know how to, on a technical level
I know how to transpose my stuff.
There are some things I wouldn't
dare to do but I can make my way
through it but most
songs belong in the keys,
in my head most songs believe in
the specific key that I wrote them
in and I can monkey around.
I Love Betsy, I wrote
in D, I play it in C
because I can't really sing
all the high notes if I do it
but it just doesn't belong in C all
that well but I can do it, it's fine
but it's supposed to be in D.
>> When you're playing
accompanying yourself,
is there much improvisation
or it's pretty much this is
the accompaniment, this is-
>> No, no, there's a
lot of improvisation.
I mean some songs, You Don't Know
This Man, there's no improvising
in that, that is specifically
what it is and a song
like The Flagmaker is going to be
largely what it is but for a lot
of my songs there's room
to interpret around it.
I mean, I am an improvising
pianist, that is part of what I do
so for me it's more fun if it
doesn't always sort of have to lock
in exactly like this all the
way and especially for the shows
that are kind of loose and groovy.
For a show like Honeymoon in
Vegas you want some of the songs
to be able to stretch
out and open up.
It's all within very
specific boundaries.
I don't reinvent the
songs when I play them,
it's just these two bars it could be
this thing or it could be this thing
but the basic feel
and harmonic structure
of it is going to be the same.
There's just filigree that
can change from time to time.
And again, I think that's
more a pop music thing.
It's basically just riffing.
I feel free to make those
changes within some of the songs
because it's part of the fun
of performing them is
to let them breathe.
>> Will you sit in your living room
and just play Isn't it Romantic or-
>> Sure, all the time.
Yeah, especially with, it was part
of the courting ritual with Georgia
to play Gershwin and sit there and
do all that but now with the girls,
the girls love to, I have two
daughters, I have a seven year old
and an eleven year old, so
the seven year old loves
to dance whenever I play the piano
so sometimes I'll just start playing
so that she'll come wandering into
my studio and start dancing around
and then wander out
again and then I'll stop.
But yeah, I play all the time.
You know, I wish I played more.
I don't get to the piano
as often as I would like to
but I think pretty much anybody
with kids would say that.
>> Does your wife also?
Do you ever fight to
get to the piano?
>> We have two pianos [laughter].
We have one in the
basement and one upstairs
so we don't have to fight to often.
>> You don't do four hand?
>> Again, the courting ritual
was a lot of four hands
which it turns out was a big thing.
Did you read that article?
There was something in The Times
I think that talked about sort
of the origin of four hand piano
was that it was back in the 1800s,
it was a way to sit in a salon, a
man and a woman would sit together
and play four hands and that the
really craft four hand arrangements
involved a lot of reaching hands
over each other and doing things
like that, and that part of it
was to allow husbands and wives
but also not husbands
and wives to interact
with each other very closely in
that way, so we did a lot of that.
We don't do an awful lot of four
hands now but again, whenever we get
to the piano now it's
usually for work so it's not
as much of that as I would like.
>> Well we got through
my first question.
>> All right good.
>> In a master class you gave,
you talked about the importance
of staging what you write
as you're writing it.
At what point in the process
as you're writing are you picturing
what the performers might be doing
on the stage?
Does that come afterwards?
>> Yeah, I don't know if it's as
specific as sort of saying you have
to walk four steps left here you
know, that I'm going to leave
to someone else to
stage it but it is
about knowing what the actors are
doing you know, what are they trying
to do and so I think I
would say to an actor know
in your head what your
staging is going to be
so that you know how
the song sort of works
because this first A section
is going to be one thing
and the second A section
is going to be another
so is there something
physical you can do to explain
to yourself why you're changing
track, what all that is.
There are times where I will
write a song where it is not clear
to me how the song is
supposed to work on stage.
I'll have just gone off
someplace and really been excited
about a certain idea musically or
a certain idea lyrically and so
for me, at that point I usually am
going to sit and say what do I want
to say to the director about
how this could be staged
so that they don't say to me well,
this doesn't make any
sense, let's just cut it.
Because if I can defend
it then I can keep it.
If I really love it then
what I want to be able to say
to the director is you don't
have to use this but it could be
that this section takes place,
here it is there's a section
of Shiksa Goddess even when it was
the song before Shiksa Goddess,
I Could be in Love With Someone
Like You but that section
of the song the state direction
always is maybe they're walking
in the park and that's
printed I think in the libretto
because it doesn't matter to me what
they're doing but if that's the way
that gets you to this
chunk of the song great,
maybe they're walking
through the park here.
Maybe that's the thing that
they're doing but what you need
to know is this isn't the same
place as where they just were.
Something different is
happening now and so you
as the director are
obliged to deal with that,
you as the actor are
obliged to deal with that
or the song is going
to feel sort of static.
You're going to feel stuck there.
>> Do you remember when you wrote
The Schmuel Song, how you visualized
in your head how it
would be performed?
>> Well Schmuel no, I think
Schmuel because it was
so clearly performative
because Schmuel is clearly
about a guy showing off this
thing, I figured they'd figure it
out one way or the other
so that was really,
I thought that was just going
to be a buffet, which it was,
just something for Daisy and
Norbert to feast all over it.
When we did the revival I added
the video elements into it just
because I didn't have, Daisy
kept Lauren or Sherry on stage
for that number so it gave Norbert
something to play to but because
in my version the other actor
wasn't on stage with Jeremy or Adam
when we first did it,
I felt the need to sort
of give a little bit more
visual life to the way
that he was telling the
story but anything goes.
>> When you see different
performers perform your numbers
in different productions, are you
surprised at the things they find
in it or how they physically
perform it?
Is that a-
>> Sometimes I mean
yeah, you know surprised,
I'm only usually surprised if
a really bad idea has shown up
and then I'm oh, oh, oh,
I didn't see that coming.
But if it's a good idea I mean,
I guess I could be surprised
but generally I'm just
sort of in the work.
If the actor is taking me along on
the journey then I just go with it
but I also don't watch a lot
of productions of my stuff.
I sort of got that out of
my system early and realized
that I wasn't generally going to be
happily surprised most of the time
and so it's probably better
that I get back to writing.
>> Do you enjoy working
with performers
in the original production?
>> Yeah, oh very much.
I always feel like I don't assert
myself enough in those situations
because I don't want to
step on the director.
You know, you hire a great
director you want to let
that person do their job and then
there will always be some point
around the recording of the
cast album where I'll say
to the actor oh well, what this
has to be is this and they'll say
to me why didn't you tell
me that three weeks ago?
I've been performing this
differently and I'm always like,
I guess I should get in there
a little bit more but yeah,
I do enjoy working with them.
I don't, there's the
specifics of like,
figuring out what note
you're supposed to sing,
working with people who are not
musically literate is exhausting
for me so there are people who love
to do that and I'm not one of them
so that's why I have
music directors.
And you know, the joys
of working with musicians
who really can just read the
material down that's like oh great,
we get to go past the sort of basics
of no it's an A natural not an A
flat and so I love that but the
on the other end of that, a lot of
those people frequently you need
to guide them through the acting
sort of bit, by bit, by bit,
by bit and they don't come up with
sort of these grand organic ways
of approaching text that you
know, more natural actors do
so you know, it's always a balance.
I like working with them because
I think I know what I want the
material to be.
>> You do so many performances
yourself where you bring
in a singer to perform with you.
Do you sort of stage direct
those individual performances?
Do you-
>> I really don't, a lot of the
times when I'm doing those concerts
and Shoshanna [phonetic] for example
who's performing with me tonight
or Eden Espinosa [phonetic] or
Megan or something like that,
usually we only have a couple of
hours that we get to work together
if that you know, so I'm trusting
that I'm hiring these
unbelievably gifted people to come
and interpret the material so
it's not where I want to go there
and say oh no, don't do this.
If they are going way afield I
will pull them back into the-
>> You decide what numbers
they're going to sing
and what the order will be?
>> Yeah, that I generally
do and you know,
sometimes they will say I'm
dying to sing Still Hurting
and I will usually say
oh great that's fantastic
and then there have also
been times where I'm like,
that's not great either because
I think it's not great for them
or because it's not a number I want
to do at that particular moment
but the concert stuff is very
separate from the process of putting
on a production of a show.
I'm much more casual about the
concert things, I sort of feel like.
>> Do you enjoy the concerts?
>> Oh I love them yeah, I mean I
think that was always what I planned
on doing and then I ended up doing,
I ended up becoming a theater guy
which I love and which is
great but the immediacy
of performance is I think the thing
that I get most excited about,
which is weird for a writer to
say but I think I'm a writer
who most enjoys sort of interpreting
the work as it goes which isn't
to say I want to be a
performer every night of my life
because I just don't much like
that but something like that.
You will hear probably
my stomach rumbling.
That's what I get for not eating
breakfast before my interview.
>> I'm sorry, sorry.
When I read through your music,
I'm just constantly sort of in awe
of your vamps and accompaniments
and the inventiveness of them
and partly also the
frequency of them.
Not every song from
other songwriters seem
to so frequently sort of
use those kinds of vamps.
They tend to seem more
chordal to me and yours,
there's always something
interesting going on underneath
and I don't know what you
can comment on about that.
>> I'm a groove guy
ultimately and so groove is sort
of how the songs are
built and groove you know,
I wouldn't use the same groove
for two different songs so even
if the tempos are pretty much
exactly the same and even
if the fields are pretty
much exactly the same,
something in that groove has to
change in order for me to write.
I really do write rhythmically
I think,
even the melodies I write are
built on a rhythmic basis.
There is an idea that a thing
goes for a certain period of time
and that the, I think it's why
I'm a lyricist is because I think
of speech in a very rhythmic
way and so once there's groove,
sort of anything can happen over it
but until I find that groove I sort
of don't know what the
song is supposed to be
and I have written a couple of songs
where I just did have sort of chords
in advance and didn't
have a real groove
and those songs always feel kind
of uncomfortable fungible to me.
Well, if it could be anything then
I guess it's just anything you know,
Stars in The Moon, when
Betty Buckley does it
with her band it's a whole different
groove that she has but Stars
in the Moon itself is specifically
that groove that I wrote into it
and I wouldn't have known how to
write the song without that pattern.
That is sort of what
drives the rest of it.
>> It may interest you, we have
several collections where it's clear
that the rhythm sort
of does come first.
In the Rodgers collection, he
has the typed lyric sheet for one
of the songs from Cinderella
and he puts in bar marks
and then writes the rhythms
and then finds the melody.
>> Yeah because with Hammerstein,
he always wrote the lyrics first
and then put the melodies
afterwards so yeah,
you can see where that would
make exactly sense there
and I think I do things like that
up here a lot all the time but yeah,
especially with popular based music
there is always a sense of meter,
that meter is kind of
what drives the thing.
I have occasionally tried to
figure out how I can write things
that are meter-less, what does
that mean and just what is it,
that would be an interesting
idea for me to try,
what is something that's
non-metered, entirely non-metered?
I find it really kind of,
even when I hear it back even
when I've written this thing
that the audience is not supposed
to perceive any kind of meter
in, I still sort of feel like no,
I still hear it, I
still know exactly sort
of where events are
supposed to happen
in a real metric sense of the word.
>> It's funny, in Bridges
of Madison County,
I was sort of following the
recording with vocal selections
and all of a sudden I
realized I think seven or eight
of the songs were either in three
four or in some triple meter.
Was that intentional?
Was that more romantic?
>> It wasn't no, I think that's
just how I played the guitar.
There was a certain strumming rhythm
that just sort of led
me to that thing.
No, not just, I mean they're all
in twelve eight or some version
of twelve eight but I mean
essentially it's the same
metronome marking.
It was really clear this
is how I play the guitar.
>> Did that surprise
you or were you-
>> It did, I really
thought I wasn't doing that.
I really thought oh
this is so clever,
I'm coming up with all
these different things
and then I just overheard
the music director saying
to the guitarist one day oh no, it's
the exact same metronome marking,
it's the same feel as the song
right before it and I was like what?
And he said no, no,
they're exactly the same.
But you know, and then when
I conducted the show I was
like no, he's absolutely right.
It was Look At Me goes
into World Inside a Frame
and they are exactly da, da, da
just exactly right in the same place
but it works, it's
what I wanted to say.
>> When you're sort of planning a
score, do you think of here's an
up tempo, it needs to be
followed by a ballad, here's-
>> Well yeah, you know,
because you're
on that particular ride you can
feel when you're just sort of stuck
at the traffic light for
too long and you can feel
when you've been going too fast
and you've got to pull it back.
You know, the energy of
storytelling I think is a big part
of what composers do.
I think if you're going
to write a musical,
mostly what you're doing
is controlling the energy
of the storytelling,
controlling the pace of it and so
to me it's very important
to stay on top
of are we going at the right speed?
Is the information being
given out at the right speed
and is the energy sort of the right
energy that we need at this moment
or have we been up for too long?
Most musicals, you hit the second
act and it's just an endless pile
of ballads which drives me bananas
and so I try never to get caught
in that trap but there's a reason
why, because as all the sort of,
as you're getting to the [inaudible]
all of the complications are sort
of coming and so everybody is
getting very reflective and very sad
and so that's why the second act
tends to be burdened by reprises
and ballads but I try to
keep that from happening.
>> Do you find the audience tells
you things when you're out of town
or in previews, you get the
sense that how they are?
>> They do but it's not so
much about that as it really is
about me sitting in
the audience being able
to experience it through their eyes.
It's not like I have some psychic
ability to feel that an audience,
you can feel when they're
really with you and you can feel
when they're not but that
changes from day to day honestly.
Even if a show works
perfectly there's some days
where the audience is really with
it and some days when they're not
so I try not to go too much on like,
oh they didn't applaud too much
tonight because you can go crazy.
But there is a sense of there is
a certain kind of state you have
to get into, a state of total
focus when you're watching a show
which is hard to do if you're the
writer because you can get trapped
by oh, I just heard the bassoon
play an E flat or you know,
why is that light going
or even just why is
that person unwrapping
a candy over here?
But that state of total focus of
I am the ideal audience member
for this piece right now, how am
I receiving it, how is it coming
at me, and so it takes a
lot and I think with all
of our endless distractions these
days it's harder for me than it used
to be to get into that state of
total focus but when you're in it,
that really is what tells
me the most about a show.
There are always some little
niggling thing in the back
of your head that says boy, this
is going on a little too long
and you can have that feeling
for like, four performances
and never really articulate it.
It just sort of comes
and then you know,
the director will say something
like something's just not right
about the top and you'll find
yourself saying actually,
it's too long.
The number is too long,
let me cut this chunk of it
but it will have taken that many
times through it for that thought
to make its way all the way from
the back of my brain into my mouth
and I find that happens a lot.
I find there are a lot of places
where the pacing just takes me a
couple of days to say you know what,
I resist cuts for a long time
not because I'm so precious
about the work but
because I generally feel
like if I've conceived it right,
it shouldn't be about cutting it.
There's something that
I did right about this
so let's not make the wrong choice.
Cutting is easy, cutting
is an easy fix.
Oh, we'll just take this out but
there is a fix that we can find.
Let's make sure it's the right one
and often it is about cutting it
but it may not be about
cutting what everyone things,
it's about cutting what happened
two minutes earlier it's that.
So I try to stay very
present and alert for it.
It's hard, it's hard, it's a
hard thing to do but I find
that I can't do it unless there's
a whole audience around me.
>> I'm curious about the
arranging and orchestrating.
Were you trained in that or was that
something from Eastman or you just-
>> When I was in high school and
we would do talent shows and things
like that, and if I wanted horn
sections because I always did
because I was a kid who wanted big
bands around me, I had to you know,
you can read about it in books but
mainly you're just doing it by ear.
Stuff like horn charts,
jazz band kind of things,
you know I would play in jazz
bands and stuff like that
so I had a certain amount of fluency
with that already but so I did some
of it in high school and knew enough
to sort of get through a chart.
They weren't particularly good
charts but I could do that.
I did study it at Eastman.
I was only at Eastman for two
years but I studied orchestration
as you do as a composition major
so I studied that and I played
in the orchestras and I got all
of that but I would really say
that the most education I got was
from watching Sebesky
orchestrate Parade.
Those charts would come in and I
would see how he was taking my work
and orchestrating it,
that the trust that he had
in some things I would
do as a pianist
and then the way he would ignore
certain things I did as a pianist
in terms of how he blew that up
so I think I really became a
vastly better orchestrator the day
that Sebesky started orchestrating
my work for me and some
of that had started earlier because
Tunick had done Petrified Prince,
which I was musical director for.
It was the Michael John LaChiusa
show and again, I had played it
and a lot of the piano arrangements
were my piano arrangements
and then watching Tunick sort of
take those on but we were working
with a very small orchestra
in that show.
It was only I think seven pieces
and so there were some lessons
that Jonathan taught me there
that I didn't really put together
for 15 years when I finally was able
to say oh, I see now why he did it
that way, I see what
he was doing back them.
But in terms of the immediate like,
I can tell you the immediate impact
that it had watching Sebesky's
charts come in for Parade.
>> I did an interview with Tunick
and I am nave when it comes
to orchestration so although
I find it fascinating,
and one of the things
that he sort of expounded
on that sparked me was the
importance of part writing
and as I understood him, he thinks
it's important as much as possible
that every instrument is playing a
piece of music, they're not filling
in a chord or something like that
because then they'll
play more musically and-
>> Yeah and I think I got that.
I think that I got intuitively
because I was a chorale singer
and I did a lot of
chorale arranging.
Vocal arranging was the thing I did
most of when I was in high school
because we had a jazz
vocal group that I was part
of that I had one teacher who was
just, she was nuts for Lambert,
Hendricks & Ross and she was
nuts for the Manhattan Transfer,
and so we would try and do all
of that stuff so I spent a lot
of time doing vocal arranging
and so because of that,
I think I intuitively knew
what Tunick was saying
which was you don't want to
just tell the altos to just sort
of hit an A in the middle of this
and then be tacit for the rest.
You want to figure out how
to get them to it musically
and so I think I try and do that as
an orchestrator also but you know,
I have a, I don't posit myself as
the world's greatest orchestrator.
I mean, I'm not a master
of it, I really do it
and I think I do it
well for my own stuff
and I have a very specific sound
as an orchestrator but I don't feel
like I really even now got an
entire handle on all of the tools
of an orchestrators trade.
I feel like I'm still sort of
masquerading as an orchestrator.
You know, there are people who spend
their lives doing it and know a lot
about color and a lot about texture
that I am really feeling
my way in the dark for.
>> When you're composing it
from the beginning do you ever
think instrumentally?
>> Oh always I mean, you know,
and sometimes instrumentally
means I'm thinking
about how the piano functions
in the piece but yeah no, no,
I've always got a pretty
clear sense but again,
because a lot of my stuff is kind
of rock based and groove based,
I'm mainly thinking about how
the rhythm section functions
and what the drums are
doing and what the,
I've got that for any
song I've written.
I know what that is supposed
to be and then you know,
for things like Parade or
Bridges of Madison County
which have a wider palate of colors,
I've generally got that in my head
as I'm writing as well but then
until you get out the paper
and start filling it out-
>> How different was
it doing Trumpet
of the Swan or something that's-
>> Trumpet of the Swan you know,
I had a very specific orchestral
template in mind and when Sam Davis,
who did the orchestrations, I just
thought there was no way I was going
to have time to do them, but so
when Sam did them I sent
him before he started,
I said these are the three pieces
that you need to know about
and I think one of
them was Petrushka,
one of them was Randall
Thompson's Second Symphony,
which is maybe the most obscure
reference I could possibly throw
out but I always loved it.
Randall Thompson I knew as a chorale
writer which is the way most kids
in high school know him because they
sing the Alleluia or whatever it was
and so I remember going to
Finkelstein Library when I was a kid
and saying what else do you
have of Randall Thompson
and there was a recording Bernstein
did of this Second Symphony,
which was sort of as close as he
ever got to a hit symphonically
and so I just remember
hearing it in high school
and just thinking it was the
greatest piece in the world.
And so, I think it was Petrushka,
the Thompson Second Symphony,
and Korngold's score for Robin Hood
and so I sent those three things
to Sam and I said these are the
basic colors we're dealing with
and there are really specific
things in Trumpet of the Swan
where clearly I'm just stealing
from one of those three pieces
and that's just sort
of what's on the table.
But you know, what I sent
to Sam was a short score,
it was largely piano part with
probably one or two other stabs
of things and then he would send
me an orchestration which I would
as often as not sort of completely
throw up in the air and re-do
but the gestures were pretty clear
and you could see them
in my short score.
I'd write woodwinds play this
chord and this thing is supposed
to be French horns playing it, it's
all pretty well delineated in there.
>> A friend of mine played bass
in Last Five Years in a production
and he said it was
the most satisfying-
>> For a bass player especially
yeah, I should hope so.
You know, that was really again,
each of the shows has a really
distinct sound by design.
I want the shows to sort of
build a world within themselves
so that any show, you can't put any
of those songs into any other show.
They sort of belong where they are
but more specifically than that,
the instrumentation that
surrounds them is very specific
to how I'm writing them so I knew
with the Last Five Years not only
was it not going to have a drummer
in it but I also knew that what I
wanted was specifically there's a
Joni Mitchell album, there's Hejira
and there's Don Juan's
Reckless Daughter,
both of which she explores the
idea of not using a drummer
but letting the fretless
bass was Jaco Pastorius,
letting that be the kind of
melodic glue that holds it together
and the guitars are
really just hard rhythm,
there's almost no guitars
soloing at all.
There's really hard rhythm
and then the melodic gestures
of the groove are all coming
from the bass and I happened to,
on Songs For a New World,
I had met Randy Landau.
We had actually met on a
benefit about a year before that
but Randy was my bass player
and he was a very fluid,
fretless bass player which
is not something that a lot
of bass players have
under their arms
and he was a great improvising
player and clearly a sort
of Jaco acolyte and so when I
was writing The Last Five Years,
I was writing it specifically
with Randy's musicianship in mind.
I actually didn't think he was going
to be able to play it at first,
because he was on the road and so
I had someone else who was going
to be learning how to play it and
I was always a little like eh,
but then Randy finally
said he was available.
>> Why was there no percussion?
>> There was no drums and the
reason there's no drums is
because I was afraid it
was going to turn the show
into a much less intimate
experience.
It would have turned the show
into a less intimate experience
because there's something
about when you have a song
like Moving Too Fast, what
you would want is the drums
to really be hitting.
You'd want a lot of volume coming
at you and what it was going to have
to do to the sound design of the
show was everything was going
to have to rise to meet
the level of the drums,
the sort of minimum
level of the drums.
Everything else was going to have
to come up far beyond the sort
of natural level and I wanted
it to feel like a chamber piece.
I mean, even in the literal sense
of the word I wanted everyone
to be able to be in the
same room at the same time
and just play the piece
and I didn't want to feel
like the minute the drummer
showed up we were all like oh,
wait let me turn up my amp
and oh wait, I've got to put
on headphones or any of that stuff.
And you know, it's
been able to be that.
It's enormously satisfying
to just sit down
and play The Last Five Years
acoustically with a bunch
of other musicians and just feel
like we can all be in the same room
and make music at the same time
and not be fighting the drummer
and the drummer does a lot
also obviously in terms
of where the tempo is, and where
the groove is and I wanted to that
to come from the section organically
so that was really the point.
But with something like Thirteen,
I wanted to sound like a bunch
of kids playing in a garage band.
I wanted it to sound sort of
noisy, and sloppy, and big and so
of course there's got to be
guitars and drums and all of that.
And Bridges of Madison County is
again, you don't want something
that is so insistent that it
pulls you out of the drama.
You don't want anything that
comes with that kind of volume
or that kind of aggression to
it so there are drums in Bridges
of Madison County but they're
feathered in very subtly
and very cleanly and it's
mainly a chamber orchestration.
And again, Honeymoon in Vegas, you
want it to sound like big bands.
What is Las Vegas supposed
to sound like?
I mean now I think Vegas sounds
like electronic dance music
but what it was supposed to sound
like in my head is Frankie and Sammy
and Dean, so you want drums, and
brass, and all of that and you know,
the stuff that's in Honeymoon in
Vegas doesn't fit anywhere else
in my cannon but it's very much me.
I think the people that know
me well think that Honeymoon
in Vegas is the most
me of all of my shows.
I live and breathe that stuff
and Parade likewise has very
orchestral textures and is meant
to sort of seem very operatic
and very big and grand.
It is an interesting place to look
as the distinction between Parade
and Bridges of Madison County,
both meant for large stages,
both meant to be big pieces but
Parade has really grand gestures
and Bridges of Madison County
has very small gestures
and those are deliberate and the
instrumentation reflects that.
>> When you say a gesture-
>> I think a gesture, you can
mean it theatrically and musically
and they both sort of mean the same
thing but a big gesture is something
that takes up a lot of room.
A big gesture can be very bold,
there's a real boldness to it.
>> Musically or-
>> Yeah well, a musical
gesture in Parade
for example is having the first
chime of the show you know,
you hear that snare
drum for eight measures
and then you hear this
enormous chime
and 12 brass instruments all
playing at the same time.
Clang, like that, that's a
big gesture, that's huge.
There's nothing like that
in the entirety of Bridges
of Madison County because it's not
a show that wants gestures that big.
It's not just about volume
but that's why not just talk
about volume as a way
to describe it?
>> You reminded, in
The Last Five Years,
this is perhaps a nave question,
you've talked about
how the larger idea
for it came to you rather suddenly.
Was there a reason
dramatically why it had
to be her going backwards
and he going forward?
Could it have been reversed?
>> I don't know when
the chicken and the egg,
whatever you say about
a chicken and egg.
I don't know however
that played out.
Once I determined that,
whether it was arbitrary or not
that she goes backwards
and he goes forwards,
it is true that emotionally
she is always looking backwards
and that emotionally he is
always looking forwards.
There is a truth to the
fact that that makes sense.
Had I decided that it should go
in the other direction then
maybe I would have justified
that in a different way.
>> They would have been
different characters.
>> Yeah, I think maybe that's true
and I think that's probably
why it just made sense to me
that she would be going backwards.
You know, what I know is that
I needed her at the beginning
of the piece to be looking
backwards on the relationship
and I think she's always
just a little behind
where he's always ahead,
ahead, ahead.
He's moving too fast and she's still
hurting you know, and so I think
that there's, that is the best
explication I can give of it.
It was, I don't think I
planned it out that way
but I can justify it after the fact.
>> I think we're running long
but I wanted to sort of close
with a couple of quotes that I sort
of found moving and
thought provoking.
>> We don't get to any of that?
>> I'm happy to do it.
I don't know how long
we're willing to stay here.
You can come back and we'll do it.
This is from an article you
wrote for The Sondheim Review.
"We want the approval
of our peers yes,
but the generations coming
next, these children,
those are the people whose approval
we truly need if our lives are
to mean anything, if our art
is not to have been in vain."
I don't know if you
remember even writing that.
>> I mean-
>> Do you have a larger sense
of yourself in the world
of musical theater
in what you're doing
in your life and how it's going?
>> I mean, I'll say really
specifically just part of what
that article is about was how
Steve had been sort of vastly upset
about when I was 22 years old,
me not responding positively
to something and I
didn't understand why
at the time he wouldn't
want me to just be honest.
Why don't you just
want me to tell you?
But what was missing in the
honesty of it was this real fear
that I have begun to have at 46,
that the work will disappear.
You know, that I will have
spent my life doing this
and that it won't be sitting here at
the Library of Congress with a lot
of people talking about it, but
that it will just have disappeared
and it will be some cute thing that
I did and that's how I spent my time
on the earth which is oh, I wrote
some songs and then they're gone.
And what is vastly
important to me in ways
that I guess it is just the ego,
but what is vastly important
to me is hearing that the
kids who come up under me,
you know the people who are starting
doing it now, when Lin-Manuel
or when Pasek and Paul, Joe Iconis,
when those people clearly
reference my work in their work
and when they will say to me how
much it means to me if I approve
of their stuff, when it's clear
that they have taken my work
and incorporated it into theirs
and are the next generation,
then I feel a little less
afraid of becoming irrelevant
but then I also have
a whole different fear
that all I will be is sort of
subsumed by these other people
who will be more successful at it.
There's no way around the sort
of perpetually fragile
ego of the artist.
You know, it is, maybe
I'm even more sensitive
than some other people are about it.
It's hard but part of the reason why
that story about Steve always was
so painful to me was not
just that I was in idiot
to not be more sensitive to
him, but that I really feel
as I get older I know
exactly where his head was.
I hope that I'm a little more
even but I can't guarantee that.
It's tricky, it's tricky being a
writer in this particular business.
It's a little weird.
>> Before we started here,
we were talking a little
bit about your daughters.
Does the sense of posterity there,
does that play into how you feel now
in terms of the significance of
your life, for lack of a better-
>> Yeah look, the thing about having
kids is they become more important
than any of the other things.
If you're doing it
for the right reason,
the kids become the whole
point and so now the writing,
I'm trying to sort of write stuff
that I care about and write stuff
that matters to me but largely
I've got to keep my family together
and it will be that way for another
10 or 15 years until they are both
out of college, and on
their way, and grown-ups
but there will be a whole span
of time that a major chunk
of my brain was devoted to making
sure the bills got paid so that
that the kids could eat [laughter].
That's where my head is these days.
>> You've talked about after
Parade, wanting to do a smaller show
or the different projects
that you've worked on,
there are different aspects working
with young kids doing Thirteen
and all that but in terms of the
subjects of the shows, and like,
the contents and what they're about
are there things that are important
to you to talk about
and that you don't want
to do a project that's just this or-
>> As I get older there are
certainly things that don't matter
to me to write about
anymore and you know,
there was specifically a period
when I had written Thirteen,
and then Honeymoon in Vegas,
and Bridges of Madison County,
and all three of those were real
attempts to roll the ball straight
down the middle of the alley.
You know, it was really I wanted
to write commercial projects,
that was what I was doing
and adapting movies is a very
specific sort of you know,
I'm taking a property and there are
people who are sort of the executors
of that property and they want
to extend the brand and I am part
of the extension of that brand
and I was in the middle of that,
and that was a 10 year
period of my life or more
and it brought me those
pieces which,
I mean Thirteen was an original
idea but certainly with Bridge
and with Honeymoon, I was very
proud of the work and very proud
of those shows but the compromises
and the negotiations involved
in having to serve the brand of
a piece, to serve the history
of a piece, of a property, the
sort of corporate nature of all
that really grated on me after
a while and so I had signed
on to write a musical based on
A League of Their Own directly
after that, and I was working on
it and I finished the first act
and I got to the end of the first
act and I looked at the show,
and I looked at the path ahead
of the show and it was good.
I thought I had done a pretty
good job and I just said,
I don't want to spend the next
four years of my life doing this
and I wrote a check to the producer
and I said sorry this didn't work
out, I don't want to do this anymore
and I did, and I haven't
regretted it for a second
because I really feel like I just
was out of the phase of my life
where I wanted to just bring other
people's ideas in that way and I had
so many things that
I wanted to write
and I think The Connector
is something I want to write
and The Matewan Project which
is about a miner's strike
in West Virginia, that's
something I very much want to do
and that Richard LaGravenese
and I are working
on a piece that's an
original idea of mine
and that those three things were
all things that I didn't want
to keep saying I'll get to them,
I'll get to them, I'll get to them.
I really wanted to write them.
And so, finding a way to do that
was important and not getting caught
up in the sort of vagaries
of entertainment for
entertainment sake.
Which again, Honeymoon in Vegas is
entertainment for entertainment sake
and I'm thrilled with it.
It's exactly what I wanted it to be.
I also don't need to spend the
rest of my career doing more of it.
>> And things that you
do personally like Hope?
>> Well you know, a song like Hope
or a song like A Song About Your Gun
and things like that,
they just come out.
I mean, I'm a writer, I
express myself that way
and even putting those songs
out in the world is a little
bit complicated for me
because I'm a little bit who am I
but I have learned that people want
to hear them and that they matter
to people and so I do say them
but I didn't sit down and write
Hope with the idea that I'm going
to put this out on my website today
and people are going
to go listen to it.
I mean you can't buy it.
It's not like I make
any money from it.
I just had to say it and
people were comforted by it
or people were something by
it, people were moved by it
and I feel like we'll write this.
That's why you're a writer.
You're a writer so you can put
your things out in the world
and they can affect people.
>> The last quote from you, I think
again you were talking about Steve
and you say, "I could have spent an
entire life worshipping at his alter
and never understanding
that such great art
as he creates can only be
born of deep vulnerability.
I have allowed myself to feel
and embrace my own
vulnerability ever since."
>> Um, I think there's a
little bit of bullshit in that.
I mean I think certainly the work
I was doing was vulnerable anyway
and I think that I got.
I was doing vulnerable
work because of again,
I grew up on Joni Mitchell,
that's a vulnerable songwriter.
That's someone that's just
putting herself out there entirely
and certainly I knew that Steve
put himself out there entirely.
There's something about being
willing to just say things
that hurt, that really
sort of feels like part
of what I want to be a writer to do.
That feels very painful
and satisfying.
I can say this is a thing that
hurts and put that out there
so I think I understood the
vulnerability of it but it's the,
if there's a question about
what I learned about my writing
from that experience with Steve,
I'm not sure that that's true.
I think that's why I wrote
that sentence but I'm not sure
that I buy it but I
think that ultimately,
what do I want to say about it?
You look forward when you're
23 years old, you're 24,
you're 30 years old,
you look forward
to what your career is supposed
to be and you're going to do it,
you're climbing up the
ladder and you look backwards
at I think Steve then would
have been late 60s, early 70s,
you look backwards at what your
career was and you can either look
at it as what it was or you can
look at it as what it wasn't
and I think I was acknowledging to
myself that there will be a point
where you look back and you can
either see only what it wasn't
or you have to look back
and see what it was.
And I still battle
with those things.
I think Steve still
battles with those things.
I think that's part of the battle,
especially if you're doing work
that is not massively commercially
successful which that is,
my work is not massively
commercially successful
so I think I do a lot of looking
back and saying what it wasn't.
But it is very important
as I am getting older
to make sure I keep looking
back and seeing what it was-
>> But do you force
yourself to continue
to be vulnerable in your work?
>> Yeah but again, that's inevitable
because the work is the work.
The work has to be honest.
You have to be honest as a
writer and you can't get hard.
An interesting way, Joni Mitchell
is someone who got very hard
as a writer that the last
two albums that she put
out were very not vulnerable.
They were very angry
records and you could sense
that that was I can't
keep opening myself
up like this you know,
at 65, at 70 years old.
I don't want to keep ripping
myself open but to me the work is
to keep ripping myself open.
I think that vulnerability is part
of what makes the work resonate
and again, in some
ways I think the degree
to which I rip myself open
is why the work is not
as commercially massively
successful as I might want it
to be but it is what's in me.
>> I'm going to close
with thanking you
but also sort of putting a plug in.
You talked about the posterity
of the manuscripts there
so I hope you're saving
everything and-
>> Yes, I'm saving an
alarming amount of work.
There's a pile of faxes
from Hal about Parade
that might not be readable
anymore but other
than that I think everything
is in pretty good shape.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Absolutely, thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.